what's fair buddy we're from finiti and  today is the final of giant ping pong we  have both Pete and Myka so now it's time  for me and Emma will go head-to-head  let's go  [Music]  [Music]  I thought you were going around the net  [Music]  Cole  right right run  [Music]  [Applause]  whoa  [Music]  a hole in the racket  [Music]  Silla  [Music]  Oh  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  Oh  [Music]  sorry [ __ ]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  so I think it was odd to us back-end  that was a bit too powerful for me today  yeah you have to run a lot because of it  yeah but there is still 78% of you guys  who have not subscribed to our channel  so remember to do that here and watch  the previous episodes there until next  time  [Applause]